[Musik]
calimera hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es
yetis zu deswegen habe ich auch eine
vokabel auch griechisch gelernt extra
für euch und früher dachten wir ganz
viele dass ich krieche wer aber ich
meine türkheim griechenland ist ja auch
nicht so weit voneinander entfernt auf
jeden fall ist es eine ehre heute das
griechische rezept galaktose co zu
machen das ist also manche sagen auf
deutsch übersetzt milch auflauf an und
seinen krimis auflauf egal was es ist
auf jeden fall sehr sehr lecker und hier
sind schon mal die zutaten habt ihr
schon mal eine übersicht wir benötigen
blätterteig dazu sage ich euch später
noch was
hier habe ich außerdem butter
speisestärke vanille zucker und weizen
gries zucker eine prise salz milch
wasser nimmt hier nochmal zucker und
eine bio zitrone und noch mal ganz kurz
zum blätterteig eigentlich wird gerlach
tobago mit viel gebracht wetter tag ist
einfacher und zugänglicher und deswegen
machen wir das heute mit blätterteig
schmeckt auch sehr sehr gut und wird
auch ganz oft genauso abgewandelt jetzt
gehen wir über zum herd und bereiten
zuallererst mal den zuckersirup zu und
für den zuckersirup das geht jetzt auch
super easy gibt er einfach wasser mit
zucker in einem topf dann lassen wir das
schön aufkochen ca 2 bis 3 minuten und
dann gehen wir die restlichen zwei zutat
mit dazu wir machen das jetzt schon
damit der in der zwischenzeit richtig
schön auskühlen kann so die zwei minuten
sind rum jetzt etwas zimt und die hälfte
der zitrone die andere hälfte benötigen
wir nämlich gleich noch für die creme
[Musik]
während unser zuckersirup in aller ruhe
auskühlt kümmern wir uns um die leckere
gries kleben die könnte ich auch so
löffeln deshalb muss ich mich immer
zurückhaltend liebe zu allah ist immer
eintopf die milch ich mach das zehn
jahre dabei ist noch nicht an
in aller ruhe und gibt dazu schon mal
alle trockenen zutaten und dann ist
wichtig dass wir das unter ständigem
rühren einmal ganz langsam aufkochen
lassen
[Musik]
unser grießpudding ist jetzt fertig und
ich gebe jetzt schon mal die butter dazu
die schmilzt dann in der rest hitze und
wenn ihr die eier dazu gerate ich euch
rückt sie vorher kurz einmal durch so
können sie dann viel besser
eingearbeitet werden und stocken dann
nicht
jetzt habe ich die eier gut
eingearbeitet der herr des wie gesagt
schon die ganze zeit ausgeschaltet wenn
ihr das jetzt noch an hättet und die
ganze hitze hier blubbern würde dann
würdet ihr wahrscheinlich spiegelei
bekommen oder das wäre einfach zu heiß
für die a
jetzt gebe ich noch zitrone dazu einmal
die hälfte der zitrone da nehme ich den
saft und ich nehme zusätzlich auch noch
die schale macht das unbedingt wenn ihr
eine bio zitrone habt für ballack tobago
ist es auch ganz typisch dass man's
zitronensaft oder orangensaft nimmt und
jetzt gerade frage ich mich rollt man im
griechischen überhaupt dass er charakter
büro oder galactic ich weiß es gerade
haben wir griechen unter uns dann könnt
ihr mir das gerne in den kommentaren
beantworten
[Musik]
und wir müssen jetzt nicht warten dass
der grießpudding auskühlt wir machen
jetzt sofort weiter ich hab jetzt hier
schon eine auflaufform bereit und die
werde ich jetzt richtig ordentlich
futtern
denn je mehr ihr da die form bist du
einfach er bekommt ihr das ballack
trikot auf später wieder raus und da
dürft ihr auch nicht geizen
übrigens ist meine form 26 x 26 cm groß
und ihr könnt ja auch ganz leicht von
abweichen das ist kein problem
[Musik]
ich verwende übrigens am allerliebsten
dem tiefgekühlten blätterteig weil
erstens wenn ihr den zehn minuten lang
auftauen lässt dann hat er so eine
schöne griffigkeit es klebt nicht an der
hand ihr könnt wunderbare auflaufform
damit belegen und man kann auch
wunderbar zu schneiden zu meiner
rechteckigen oder fertigen auflaufform
passt es am allerbesten
da hab ich jetzt den boden ausgelegt das
habt ihr gesehen und jetzt geben wir
einfach vollständig die creme obendrauf
und obendrüber kommt dann noch mal eine
schicht blätterteig
[Musik]
und so sieht das ganze jetzt aus
obendrüber eine schöne blätterteig
schicht und jetzt ist es ganz ganz
typisch dort rauten einzuschneiden unter
euch ein schönes scharfes messer und
schneidet die ganz einfach eine müsste
auch nicht bis ganz unten gehen das
reicht wenn ihr nur die oberfläche
durchschneidet
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die oberfläche noch mit
einem verkohlten bestrichen das ist
natürlich optional aber ich finde dass
sie dann immer schöne auswahl dass man
richtig schön bräunt jetzt kommt das
ganze in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
180 grad ober unterhitze gibt es am
besten die untere einschub leiste und
dann dauert so 30 bis 35 minuten aber
ihr werdet zu merken wenn es richtig
schön goldbraun ist dann ist unser
charakter bonnekoh fertig fast fertig
denn dann kommt noch unser zuckersirup
ist gleich
[Musik]
und genau so muss es aussehen richtig
schön goldbraun bei mir hat exakt 34
minuten gedauert und jetzt gehen wir
auch unser heißes galaktose rico ist
ganz frisch aus dem ofen kommt unseren
kalt mit zuckersirup darf auch ruhig
noch lauwarm sein hauptsache der ist
nicht heißt einfach drüber gehen und
dann nochmal ordentlich einziehen lassen
[Musik]
und jetzt muss das ganze noch richtig
schön kühlen am besten gibt ihr das für
mindestens zwei stunden in den
kühlschrank nachdem es halt leicht
abgekühlt ist also nichts heißt in den
kühlschrank geben das ist er nicht so
förderlich aber ihr könnt das auch gerne
am vortag zubereiten dann habt ihr das
für den nächsten tag und es konnte über
nacht richtig schön durchziehen
ich zeige euch aber natürlich noch den
anschnitt und freue mich wenn er das
ganze jetzt nach macht und nimmt der
infobox schreibe ich euch die genauen
mengenangaben auf und dann freue ich
mich wenn ihr mir fotos zukommen lassen
mit dem hashtag s kitchen auf instagram
darüber freue ich mich wirklich sehr
und dann bin ich gespannt ob ich das
genauso gut schmeckt wie uns und dann
sage ich bis zum nächsten mal auf dieses
kitchen jack's
[Musik]